dehors une affaire qui marche c'est
celle de bourbourg 40000 visiteurs
aujourd'hui en fin d'après midi trois
mille personnes attendaient encore de
pouvoir entrer le grand navire de verre
a réussi son lancement
c'est la ruée vers l'art pourquoi un tel
engouement pour le centre georges
pompidou entreprises après tout dont on
dit autant de mal que de bien
quelles sont vos impressions vous étiez
venu par curiosité sans curiosité oui
mais je trouve que le musée très bien
agencé
il ya beaucoup de diversité c'est clair
se mange 37 un petit reproche c'est rien
pour ce soir ça me rappelle beaucoup les
reports de roissy où sera une grande
journée
je me suis finalement si ça va ça pour
après le travail soit entendu
donc moi ça je pense que c'est tous les
restes de matériaux qui restent des
aéroports qui fut devancé faut que je
revienne seul d'ailleurs on était
nombreux et on n'a pas eu le temps de
s'arrêter pour voir vraiment sous les
vents la bibliothèque j'ai pas plus
attendre pour rentrer je pense que les
gens ont l'impression qu'il ya un lieu
ouvert à eux où ils peuvent passer leurs
loisirs dans des conditions beaucoup
plus intéressante que celle que les
conditions qu'ils avaient avant et je
suis persuadé que peu à peu ils
signeront à l'arrêt la lecture la
bibliothèque est un succès considérable
nous avons des livres lus par tout le
monde la salle d'actualité rencontre un
très grand accueil à tous les degrés à
tous les nouveaux zoo ferons quelque
chose aux gens qui peut leur plaît et je
crois que cette multiplicité de
possibilité qui leur est ouverte
cette possibilité dans quelques mois de
voir d'autres choses différent de ce que
nous voyons aujourd'hui j'ai le grand
espoir que le succès de ce semblait pas
un feu d'artifice mais qu'il va durer
donc dès que si curiosité saine
curiosité très bonne curiosité et à fait
au point pourquoi ne s'attend pas
curieux